good morning class if you're here to
learn how to type faster on one of these
you're in the wrong place
mavis peakins classes across the hall if
you're here to learn how to type on one
of these unfortunately we no longer
offer that class but don't worry by the
time you're done here today you'll be
able to type just as fast on a piece of
glass Android lets you choose from a
number of different keyboard apps that
speed up how fast you can input text and
now as so does the iPhone they're faster
than any hardware keyboard but they're
not created equal please take out your
phones so we may begin flexi SwiftKey
swipe a I type min UUM of all the
keyboard replacements
I like SwiftKey the best with Swift key
and swipe you don't have to press on the
letters instead you can just swipe your
fingers over the keys to create a word
based on where your fingers travel it
almost miraculously creates a word out
of what you're trying to type it's great
for those one-handed situations and both
can even figure out hard words like
existential but I can still type faster
when I have two thumbs handy and thanks
to good key spacing and with Swift key
is easier to type on at forty five to
fifty words per minute
it beats Google's Android keyboard for
me but I can still type faster in
Apple's at 55 words per minute but the
real appeal of Swift key is how good it
is at learning your vocabulary and
predicting what you're going to say next
but the key to really speeding up your
typing is installing a keyboard app that
lets you create shortcuts or macros for
text you repeatedly type for the iPhone
I found that the $2 Qui board is the
best option you can save chunks of text
you frequently type like your work or
email address and instantly insert it
into a message on Android I become
hooked to a I type it's a full keyboard
but has the ability to add macros when I
type the letters a DRS it inserts my
entire work address
we typing teachers don't like to talk
too much about pens or styluses but I
offer some tips for those of you who
think you can write faster than you can
type stack for the iPhone converts your
writing to text but it hasn't been great
about recognizing my sloppy penmanship
stylus beta for Android is much better
and it's easier to put in spaces between
words now class to recap if you're
looking to speed things up on your
iPhone or Android phone your best bet is
Swift key especially if you only have
one hand handy for saving time on the
stuff you repeatedly type try keyboard
for the iPhone and a I type for Android
that's all for today your homework
assignment is to type the entirety of
war and peace with just swipes I will
see you all then